team this is the seventh best offensive
rebounding club in the lead and hooker
step to the lane for the steel and
muscles is where it was the glass but
can't catch a break
Warren in the left-hand batting around
bunkers got it and finally gets to
finish it Warren is down again
ugly shots have we seen this son's
defense ports through this first half
deep three on the way for Booker bottoms
up
[Applause]
now some of the things that he has
talked about with his team on the road
which has been great you could talk
about them being young and Devin poke
them with a nice turnaround is you got a
lot of young guys on this team that are
learning how to be a professional
learning how to play the game Booker on
the catch it shoot the high arching
rainbow drops it in but yeah and
enforced it to really take a challenge
shot is Chandler takes the alley-oop
feed from Booker and hammers it home you
can see Tyson Chandler kind of coming
over there and then he just slips in
hooker kind of draws and B to him and
Abita as they get the switch
Booker blowing past impede and quickly
snaps it down on the offensive end now
not surprisingly third quarters says
Booker takes to put back your feed and
then I on cheeks shot in the third
quarter only to have the Pistons rally
and make the game far closer than they
thought that should have been and all of
a sudden Devin hooker accepted swatting
away by Mb Lulu come alone has it
knocked out of bounds by Booker right
back in final 9 seconds here's Booker on
the drive
gets inside left-hand finish in the foul
play by Devin Booker and I think okay it
wanted women shot clock down and game
clock that he has the drive on the left
side plots to inbound a basketball
anyway any but is your point is spot-on
hooker hangs and hits time side look
they're trying to split the double-team
he does gets inside right hand and the
footage
he's got 33
[Music]
Booker gets free for three so many other
players have stepped up their game
Booker tied up by Redick raising up
loitering and hitting team locked in
defensively here on the same shot Booker
with the steal
gets down at third quarter to give
credit to the sun's defense hooker long
range on the way and oh my goodness 25
or more brook crossing over stouts get
step back guys
[Applause]